réactions à présent du président du
parti debout la france nicolas dupont
aignan il a réagi depuis à l'assemblée
nationale on les compte c'est le début
d'une guerre civile
et si on réagit pas très vite il y en
aura encore d'autres
donc moi la seule question que je pose
c'est quand on comprendra qu'il faut
réagir
voilà c'est tout c'est combien de morts
combien décapitation combien
d'égorgement il faudra attendre car il
suffit pas de nommer le mal il faut
maintenant agir c'est à dire faire ce
qu'on a dit depuis des semaines des mois
des années
ce que j'ai demandé l'expulsion des
fichiers as étrangers j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi avec monsieur les
barres sur
un délit de prédication subversive
islamistes parce que là on voit bien ce
que c'est une guerre totale à la fois
mené sur le sol intérieur sans doute
inspiré par l'extérieur
donc cela veut dire maintenant qu'il
faut vraiment passer aux actes